oh
[Musique]
elle n'entraîne pas des astronautes mais
l'estac à montigny-le-bretonneux à sa
filière spatiale l'école forme des
ingénieurs ce qu'ils pensent les
lanceurs les engins ou l'exploitation
des satellites
enfin phil hay cette position vingt ans
qu'il attend de
novembre 2014 comme un accomplissement
pour les équipes de l'eau vs q le
laboratoire de l'université versailles
saint quentin a participé à
l'élaboration de cet instrument sur
rosetta et leur beau fils a est lové
excuse c'est aussi du vs cul ça tu le
nano satellites du latmos placé en
orbite en janvier 2021 ou encore
persévérance de rover présent sur la
planète mars
[Musique]
le rover persévérance est d'ailleurs
équipé d'une caméra wi entend un laser
un dispositif conçu dans les yvelines à
buc plus précisément derrière la
conception 3d plus
maître d'oeuvre d'ariane 5 ariane 6 le
groupe du même nom a son siège aux
mureaux il vient de décrocher un contrat
etc amazon pour 18 lancement de son
dernier fleuron sur trois ans des
lanceurs spatiaux réutilisables aux
loges en josas laboratoire de sur you
space services pense à la mise en orbite
de satellites créée en avril 2020 la
start-up emploie 35 collaborateurs
encore en phase de développement le
premier vol inaugural est prévu en 2025
l'espace est aussi une histoire de
passionnés ils n'en font pas leur métier
mais scrute souvent le ciel plusieurs
clubs d'astronomie sont présents dans le
département comme celui de vélizy
villacoublay où deux plaisirs le radio
club de saint quentin en yvelines a même
participé à la mission de l'ue est ce qu
sat
[Musique]